Let's just start it from the
top. Okay. You Ready? All right.
So for reporter Sheri Fink who works at
the New York Times and is author of the
book five days at Memorial, you could
say it all began with two tents.
So this was back in 1999
[inaudible]
the u s and other,
I think NATO allies were involved
in a bombing campaign in Serbia.
This is basically like last gasps of
[inaudible] war in the former Yugoslavia.
You had Serbia attacking
ethnic Albanians in Kosovo.
NATO was trying to protect
them, bombing Serbia,
which was creating a huge
exodus of refugees. Now,
Sherry at the time was not
yet fully or reporters.
She was fresh out of med school,
volunteering at a human rights
organization working on a book about a war
hospital in Bosnia. And
since she knew the landscape,
she was able to convince this
organization to let her go to Macedonia to
document what was happening to
document potential war crimes.
So I remember I went to the border of
Kosovo and Macedonia and like 100,000
refugees had shown up.
They were trying to cross
the border into Macedonia.
But the Macedonian government had
closed its border with Kosovo,
so people who were fleeing got trapped.
They got stuck in this muddy no
man's land between the two borders.
She said police and Rike your were
basically lining the Macedonian side.
So you had all of these people crammed
into this muddy channel and the
Macedonian Red Cross and this one
charity had gotten permission to set up a
makeshift medical station
in that border area.
Between these two countries, there's
a sort of frumpy brown medical tent.
Now Sheri was there to conduct
interviews, nothing to do with medicine.
I was there to collect
information, but when I got there,
I literally remember walking up to
this border and a doctor who I had
interviewed previously,
this really tall Albanian Kosovo Albanian
doctor looked out and he told the
Macedonian border guard, let her
in. We need her. She's a doctor.
They just grabbed you and pulled
you into this tent? Yes. What?
So you're just out of med
school? When this happened,
I had just finished med school. Yeah.
Suddenly she says she was tossed in with
all these war doctors and here's the
key. Eventually she gets
posted at the door of the tent.
And what I ended up doing,
or what they put me in
charge of was triage.
No [inaudible]. It's a, it's a French
word. Nice. Excellent. Yes, thank you.
Ah, it means to sort
or to sort for quality.
Originally it was a reference
to sorting coffee beans,
actually sorting
different kinds of coffee.
But a few hundred years ago,
the word started being applied to people
to actually sorting different kinds of
casualties on the battlefield.
And that suddenly was her job.
Literally, I stood outside of this
makeshift medical
station and every minute,
every couple of minutes there would be
another patient brought to the door of
our medical tent.
And so my job was to stand outside that
door and decide who gets in and who
doesn't. Like how did you do that?
How did you make that choice? Well,
I don't remember having guidelines.
I remember just having to wing it.
She says she just went on instinct.
And so the people who seemed like they
might be having a heart attack or a
seizure, those were the ones who
went into that tent. But you know,
people with physical disabilities, no
people who have chronic conditions,
no psychiatric issues,
nope. Everybody else.
I had to direct to this other tent and
someone ended up calling it the tent of
the damned
[inaudible].
I remember appealing for help from
the Macedonian Health Ministry saying,
you know, take these people into
Macedonia. They're not a threat. Um,
open your board or take
them in. They need care.
And the health ministry kept refusing.
And so they stayed in
this tent day after day.
[inaudible]
sometimes for four, five, six days.
And several of the people
in this tent, they died.
Cherry says this experience haunted her.
And years later when she was a full blown
reporter and traveling all around the
world, looking at triage
and different scenarios,
she would return to this memory
again and again. And wonder,
how do people in that situation
make that decision? How should they
today a collaboration
with the New York Times?
We're gonna follow reporter Sherry think
through the INS and outs of triaged in
three different situations,
three different places in the world as
she tries to understand what it means to
play God. I'm Jad Abumrad
I'm Robert Krulwich.
This is Radiolab. Stay with us.
[inaudible]
are we rolling? Yeah. Okay,
thank you. It's going to get, oh,
he's gonna get some water. Okay.
By the way, we know we're
going to start with Kosovo.
When did you as a writer become obsessed
with all of this? Well, well this,
this,
this obsession of about triage came
about when I was working on my last book
[inaudible] five days at Memorial,
which was about triage in a,
an emergency in Hurricane Katrina.
This is the scenario that people in
New Orleans had been fearing for a long
time. A category five hurricane
headed right toward the city. Okay,
so this is going to be a first stop.
We all in New Orleans have heard the
story of Katrina told and retold. Um,
certainly it's hard not to think about
now with what's happening in baton rouge,
but in this story, the hurricane
is really just a backdrop really.
We're going to focus in on one building.
This Hospital Memorial Medical Center
built in 1926 in one of the lowest parts
of that city, which is really like a
bowl. It was a sturdy brick building,
eight stories tall,
stretching over two city blocks that had
served in every storm until that point.
It was really seen as somewhere safe.
[inaudible] I don't want to leave. Merriam
and this hospital became for Sherry,
a kind of portal into these
questions about triage.
She ended up spending six and a half years
interviewing doctors at the hospital,
patients, nurses, family members,
government officials, ethicists,
hospital administrators in all.
She conducted over 500
interviews to reconstruct
moment for moment what happened
at the hospital during Hurricane Katrina
[inaudible]
get ready.
This is the most intense part of the
storm is getting ready to come across
day one, Monday, August
29th, 2005 around 6:00 AM
Katrina Harris.
I've never seen anything in my
life like this and all that.
They get it
through the storm. Okay,
the city power's gone,
but they've got their backup
power. But this hospital,
it had a vulnerability a lot
of American hospitals have,
which is that they had
moved the generators to the
second floor so that they
would be higher up in case of flooding.
But electricity is all about circuits.
And they had elements of that backup
power system that were below flood level,
things like switches and
other electrical material,
but they got through the first day. Okay.
And it seemed at that point that
the worst was over. And then
you have heard about that water coming
over that no. When did the song rise up?
Actually, after the coal made
it clear though the levies
water surrounds this hospital,
it fills New Orleans,
and as the water started to
rise around the hospital,
that is the moment that the people in
charge knew they were in big, big trouble.
They knew what their vulnerability was.
How many patients were in the hospital
at this point? There 250 patients.
There are about 2000 people because you
had so many wow staff and then all the
visitors who had come with the
staff members and with the patients.
So Sherry says mid morning on
that second day, this is Tuesday,
August 30th just as the
waters were starting to rise,
a group of doctors got together and they
did come up with a system which evolved
a little bit over the crisis,
but they decided first get the babies out,
get the critical care patients out,
and they knew that they had two high
water trucks from the national guard and
the water wasn't so, so high yet.
At that point it was only partway up
the sloping emergency room ramp and they
decided to put patients who
could walk on those trucks. So
[inaudible]
helicopter start to arrive.
A medical staff start to bundle
tiny babies in incubators,
ICU patients in wheelchairs onto the
elevator and up to the hell a pet.
How many patients can a
single helicopter take? Yeah,
like the ones that were landing, how
many can they do? One or two. Wow.
So this is slow going. Yeah,
it was late evening before they got all
the intensive care unit patients out and
they get all the babies and
they get all the babies. All in,
all in that second day,
they evacuated about 60 people that
are 60 of the most critical patients.
Although we should also say that
if a patient had signed a DNR,
a do not resuscitate order,
the doctors decided those patients should
not go first and they were held back.
And we'll sort of explain their
thinking on that in just a second. Okay.
So darkness falls on day two. The
doctors and nurses are exhausted.
They'd been working really, really
hard carrying patients in the heat.
Many of them lay down on cots and
vacant beds to rest for the night.
And then
before the sunrises, few hours before
about 2:00 AM the buzz of
the generators suddenly just
stopped. It's quiet.
The water had reached those electrical
switches in the basement. Dr Dr. Cook,
Ewing Cook, a longtime ICU doctor.
He was lying not far from where those
generators were. And he said to me,
it was quote, the sickest sound
of his life found absence. Yeah.
And that is when it became
an absolute emergency.
In this hospital.
It's pitch blackness. Some
of the medical equipment,
if they have backup batteries,
they started beeping to warn that
the electrical power had stopped.
You still had nine patients who
relied on ventilators to breathe.
It became a hive of activity,
I think gotta get everyone out.
Everybody was running
around with flashlights.
These beams in the blackness
trying desperately to move
those patients down the
stairs. Now there's elevators.
That's the other big thing.
Fortunately somebody found a hole in the
machine room wall on the second floor
that led directly to a parking garage,
and so they figured out they can pass
patients through this roughly three by
three foot hole onto the
back of a pickup truck,
drive them up to the eighth story of that
parking garage and then carry them up.
Three rickety flights of steps
to this formerly unused helipad
and five of the nine patients
on ventilators died just right.
Then.
It's just like I said, I've been
trying to put it away. Yeah,
but I want to make this as
accurate as I can for you.
This is tape of an interview that Sherry
did back in 2008 when she was doing
research for this story.
Okay, good. Introduce yourself. My
name is gene is bell is bell. Okay.
Just like it's spelled.
Gina was a nursing director working on
the seventh floor of the hospital that
day.
She'd actually been attending to those
nine patients that didn't make the first
helicopter run.
And she described to Sherry that right
after the power went out and after the
ventilators shut down, one
of her patients flatlined.
And um, we brought him back.
We had run out of oxygen.
Oh, hospital. That's what she'd
been told. And he needed oxygen.
And so we brought him down the
stairs to the second floor.
They brought him down in the dark and
then got in line to wait for their turn to
go through the hole in the
wall up to the heliport window.
And she says that since his
ventilator wasn't working anymore,
the whole time they were standing there,
they had the hand squeeze this ventilator
bag to keep air going into his lungs.
You know, he kept twitching
and I knew he needed oxygen.
And so I was in line and it
was my turn at the window.
I kept bagging him and bagging him. One
of the physicians came over and said,
you do know that he needs the
oxygen? I said, yes sir. He said,
we don't have any oxygen can,
we can't get any and
you have to let him go.
And at that point, you know,
I'm standing there and I'm
like, how do you do this?
Heidi did just let him go.
But he was right. I mean,
I knew what were neurological and that
he needed oxygen and he wasn't gonna make
it without it.
So I just hugged him and his hair and
I waited and just kinda held him
and he died in my arms. And, um, you know,
you're not prepared for that.
I had to take out of the bar, the room
[inaudible]
so I rolled them out and the morgue was
full and the chaplain came over to me
and he says, come on with me.
And we took the body into the
chapel and I just did the,
and I just bust out crying and
he just held me and we prayed.
And um, why did he laugh?
I just sat the chapel for a few minutes
and uh,
try to compose myself a little bit,
be prepared to help people
and to save people. You know,
it's just not enough.
Everything you've done is just not enough.
Day three, Wednesday, August 31st,
2005 sunrises and that's when they're
expecting all the helicopters come back
and they wait and they wait and they
wait and an occasional helicopter comes.
But this concerted rescue effort that
had taken place the evening before has
stopped. Now we know now looking back
on that Wednesday, the helicopters were
doing their own triage coast coastguard,
rescuing people and looking at
people on rooftops waving rags.
It's higher family is on that roof, right?
[inaudible] but the people
inside the hospital,
most of them had no idea.
All they knew was we're in
this horrific situation.
Where are the helicopters at this point?
There's still nearly 200 patients at
the hospital. And some of the staff,
they're panicked because it takes them
so long to move the patients to the top
of the parking garage just
below that hell a pad,
so she says on that third day
at about seven in the morning,
a bunch of doctors and
hospital administrators, maybe
a dozen, dozen and a half.
They got together and they
decided that they needed a system,
a way of organizing their patients so
that when those helicopters started to
show up again, they wouldn't
waste any time at all.
They'd know exactly who to evacuate
in what order. In other words,
who are we going to get out first?
That was the question and that's the
moment where they come up with the ones,
twos and threes. This is triage.
There are limited number
of resources in this case,
helicopters and a few boats and we have
to decide which people get access to
those resources.
There are a couple of ways
to look at this. Sherry says,
if you go back to the very beginning
of triage, the first conception of it,
1790s Napoleon's
chief surgeon baron, Larry,
I think you made a rule on the battlefield
that you'd take the people who are in
the acute need first.
So the sickest are going to be treated
first and with the most resources,
and this is the way it works
in most emergency rooms,
there's a long waiting line of fevers
and cuts, but if you got a heart attack,
you get right to the front of the line.
Another way to look at it
is the utilitarian concept.
It's got to start with some philosophers
in the 18th and 19th centuries.
The core of this idea seems simple,
try to do the greatest good.
You want to maximize some sort of
good outcome amongst a population.
So rather than think about what
one individual needs, you think,
how can I save the most number of lives
or the most number of years of life?
If we want to maximize years of life,
we might want to pick people who are,
have a better chance of
surviving or younger people.
And this method of triage is what you
often see in a war zone where say there's
a bombing and you have more
injured victims than there
are ambulances or medics.
So one, two, three.
Imagine a lobby area in a hospital
waiting area. Sherri says, in this case,
what the doctors did. They ask the staff
to get everyone out of their rooms,
bring them down to that second
floor lobby, and then some doctors,
including one whose name might be
relevant for later, Dr Anna Poe,
she was a head and neck
surgeon, she and another doctor,
they stationed themselves on the landing
where the patients were brought down to
on that second floor. And as
the nurses would bring them,
they would look quickly
at the patient's chart,
look at the patient
and decide on a number.
And the nurses would take a magic marker
and a piece of paper and write either
one, two or three on that paper.
And then she says they would tape
that number onto the patient's gown.
So the ones where you're
relatively healthy, patients,
patient maybe who had an
appendicitis and their appendix out,
but they're looking good.
They could even be discharged.
The ones would be rescued by boat.
Presumably among the first the twos were
your more typical hospital patients.
Patient may be who had a heart
attack, who wasn't fully recovered,
who would need ongoing care.
They would go by helicopter,
presumably second,
and then the threes were those super
sick patients or anyone with a do not
resuscitate order. Those patients would
go last one of the doctors when I said,
why did you choose the sickest patients
to go last? One of them said, well,
I figured anyone with the do not
resuscitate order would have a terminal or
irreversible condition, which by the
way isn't always the case. And he said,
I thought that that patient would
have quote the least to lose.
So it sounds like in some way they
went to more of a utilitarian way of
thinking. Yeah.
And you could see everything that
follows as flowing from that utilitarian
decision.
And actually they it a few different
points to prioritize the healthiest people
first. And the sickest people last,
his choices ultimately did become, um,
very consequential. In any case,
all three groups were placed in different
parts of the hospital and the threes
were kept in the lobby. The second
floor lobby [inaudible] just
way too
[inaudible].
So as the day goes on the area started
to get really full patient next to
patient on these cots in one corner she
says you had about 18 people lined up
side by side and these were people with
heart conditions, symptoms of pneumonia,
stroke. There were nurses standing
around fanning people. It just,
it was so, so hot.
Some people guessed that the temperature
inside the building must have been a
hundred degrees.
I don't know if there's any way for me
to describe to you how intense the heat
was. This is Dr Anna [inaudible]
in an interview with 60 minutes.
She was one of the doctors who did
the numbering. It was relentless.
It was suffocating and made it extremely
difficult to breathe and with the heat
came the terrible smell. It's
just started to smell really good,
bad enough. The bathrooms were so bad.
That's Gina Isbell again, she said sewage
was sort of backing up in the toilet.
I mean they just had to word
everywhere on the ground everywhere.
You just personally,
I didn't want to eat or drink anything
cause I didn't want to have to use the
bathroom.
As the day went on, some people
started really feeling abandoned.
Why aren't they here? Why
aren't they helping us?
We're in a war zone here.
It looks like a war zone.
On the seventh floor there was this radio
that was playing in the corridors past
six o'clock here on welcome to the local
talk station and the radio was this
radio station.
One of the only ways they were
getting information from the outside,
the mindset, the needs,
the hunger, the anger,
the rage is growing among some of the
nurses have carts that they would roll
around and they'd have the little radio
on the cart and they'd be listening.
Basic jungle.
Human instincts are beginning to creep
in and there were tales on the radio that
were alarming. The staff,
someone is breaking into businesses and
alluding merchandise and these people
should be shot. Things that turned
out not to be true, like you know,
run a martial law here that
they had declared martial law.
There was literally a deputy sheriff who
got on air and told people that we even
both commented said out, it
looked like a shark's fin.
He saw a shark swimming around a
hotel. They're walking like zombies,
like nights of the living
dead. That'll just imagine, oh,
that would feel if you were
in this hospital and that
was the only word you were
having about what going on outside.
One of our employees was like having a
breakdown freaking out in the garage.
By the afternoon of that
third day, that Wednesday,
some of the staff are having nervous
breakdowns. Morale is really,
really low because all these
patients are still there. Basically
patients was so hot, you know,
they would just kind of drift off to sleep
and you have to wake them up and make
them take sips of water, sips
of 'em, whatever. We had,
you know,
city of New Orleans one day
I'm Amanda's Bay, Hello Guy.
One of the nurses told me she was worried
that there could be brain or lasting
effects of this severe overheating
[inaudible]
so there's this level of, of panic.
What happened? Well,
so there is also the
situation of the pets,
and this may make no sense to most people,
but they would offer staff members,
they could bring their pets if they
were coming in to work a storm and they
turned medical records over into a Kennel
and people start to worry about their
pets. Apparently on that Wednesday,
one of the larger dogs in Newfoundland
started having seizures from the heat.
So some of the staff chose to
have doctors euthanize their pets
and then just
try to imagine if you can,
looters are running free.
It's trying to shatter windows and
climate in the stores. It's hot.
People are dying. You're hearing gunshots
in the neighborhood, you're afraid.
Just total chaos.
You don't know if there's real
violence breaking out in the city.
There are bodies floating
in the water there.
You don't know how many rescue resources
are going to come. It's nighttime.
And your colleague walks up
to you and says, you know,
we're euthanizing the pets to
put them out of their misery.
What about these suffering patients?
Shouldn't we put some of
them out of their misery
and I interviewed all these people and
trying to figure out like where did this
idea come from and tracing it back and
there were all these little informal
conversations
[inaudible]
and this starts just going
around the hospital. This,
this sort of idea of putting
patients out of their misery.
I don't know who told me
that, but that's what I heard.
And you know, in those circumstances,
what do you do if you're at war and
you have someone that's not going to be
picked up and you can't carry them to
safety and they're bleeding to death,
what did he do? Yell at
himself off to yell at him.
I don't know.
Jerry says that as this idea
spread around the hospital,
people fell into different camps.
Some people thought this was the
most humane thing they could do.
It would be criminal to
let people suffer more.
Other people when they heard about
it were outraged. For example,
Dr. Bryant King, whose colleague, Dr
Fournier, she walks up to him and says,
there's this discussion going on and you
know, what do you think? And he says,
dude, you gotta be kidding me to to
actually think that that's a good idea.
This is Dr. King in an interview on CNN,
how could you possibly think
that that's a good idea?
[inaudible]
day four, Thursday, September 1st,
here's what ends up happening.
And accounts here are a
bit vague and in dispute,
but according to Dr. King who
spoke about this on CNN, he says,
and other people say they
saw this as well. He says,
he saw one of the doctors we
talked about earlier, Dr Anna Poe,
who is still there that Thursday
morning caring for patients.
These patients on the second
floor who were chosen to go last.
He says he saw her talking to patients
while holding a handful of syringes.
Anna standing over there with a handful
of syringes talking to a patient and the
words that I heard her say,
where I'm going to give you something
to make you feel better. Nice.
He had a handful of syringes,
I don't, and nobody,
nobody walks around with a handful of
the ranges and goes and gives the same
thing, these patients that
that's just not how we do it.
Did you afford for a beat?
After this whole ordeal was over and
the rescue teams in the mortuary teams
arrived, many bodies were
found in this hospital,
about 45 bodies found. And so there
was an investigation launched.
They found these bodies, they
tested these bodies for drugs.
And what they found was that nearly
two dozen patients had received either
morphine or verse,
said a powerful sedative or a combination
of the two in a very short time period
on that Thursday, September
1st, 2005. So again,
how many it was I think 21 in the end.
But it's complicated in medicine.
What is comfort and what is murder depend
to a large degree on the intentions of
the doctor. It's called the
principle of the double effect.
It's sometimes credited to St Thomas
Aquinas and it's this idea that,
uh, an act that that can cause harm.
But if your intention is to do good,
then that's ethical.
And Dr. Anna Pope, did
you murder those patients?
As the attorney general alleges? No,
I did not murder those patients and I
want everybody to know that I am not a
murderer, that we are not murderers.
In that 60 minutes interview,
Dr Poe flatly denies euthanizing anybody
and at various points in the interview,
she is clearly distraught
at the accusation.
It completely ripped my heart out
because my entire life I have tried to
do good and my entire adult life I have
given everything that I have within
me to take care of my patients.
But Sherry did talk to one
doctor, Dr. Ewing Cook.
We mentioned him earlier when we
were talking about the generators.
He's a doctor who deals a lot with end
of life care and he was very open with
her about the decisions he
made. He had gone upstairs,
visited Mrs. Burgess cancer patient to
see how she was doing and he was just
thinking to himself, she's so sick.
She's got advanced cancer.
I can't imagine she would have
more than maybe a week to live.
At the best of circumstances.
She is weighted down with fluid,
which can happen toward the end
of life. So she weighs a lot.
She's on the eighth floor, so
we'd have to carry her downstairs.
And plus there's four nurses
up here taking care of her.
Couldn't we use them somewhere else?
So he literally turned to
one of the nurses and said,
can you give her enough
morphine till she goes
[inaudible]
and that nurse charted huge increase
in morphine for her and she died.
And that was his thought. So he
made this decision and to this day,
or at least the last time we spoke,
he felt he did the right thing.
He said to me, he thought it was
desperate. He saw only two choices,
quicken their deaths or abandoned them.
And I mean if that was the real situation,
there's some ethicists would say either
of those choices would be, you know,
not justified but excusable.
But one of the arguments you could make
is that when you give up on one person,
it then becomes a little bit easier to
give up on the next person and then the
next person. And then suddenly
you're on a slippery slope.
And Sherry did tell us
about this one case.
His case was very haunting and at Everett,
61 year old doting
grandfather, very, very heavy.
He weighed 380 pounds and he was up
on the seventh floor of the hospital.
He was conscious, alert, fed
himself breakfast, asked his nurses,
are we ready to rock and roll? He
said to one nurse who never forgot it,
Cindy, don't let them leave me behind.
Don't let them leave me behind.
But he had had a spinal cord
stroke. He couldn't walk.
He was on the seventh floor of the
hospital with no working elevators.
And the staff told me they
couldn't imagine how they
would carry him down those
flights of stairs, let alone would
a helicopter take a man of his size.
And he was one of the patients who was
found with this drug combination in his
body. And he was, and he died. He
died, found his body was found.
And by the way,
the other tragedy was just as those
injections took place was when the
helicopters finally were
focused on this hospital.
[inaudible]
did a judge or a jury find anyone guilty
of manslaughter or murder or second
degree murder or no? Nobody. No.
Nobody ended up getting convicted.
And again, just to remind
you how quickly a hospital can go
from a normal American well-regarded
functioning hospital to a place where
this was even considered and discussed was
so short. A Monday morning,
the storm hits Tuesday morning,
the water rises early Wednesday morning
all power goes out and this is Thursday.
Wow. That's kind of chilling to think
[inaudible]
got it.
If all of that began with a
triage decision about which
patient should go first,
I'm trying to put myself in the position
of the people at that hospital and I'm
thinking to myself, God, it'd be
really nice to have like a checklist,
like a checklist on a wall that says
here's how you do this so that I can just
check the boxes cause God I wouldn't be
able to think my way through that. Yeah.
That's where I go next.
I wonder whether this story you've
just told us leads us anywhere.
The first place it would lead me would
be to ask is there a system that people
could set up,
people who are reasonable and who have
the expectation that something like this
is going to happen again somehow
somewhere maybe in my town, my hospital,
my place. So what could we do
to make this not happen?
Well it's interesting you asked
because of course after Katrina,
there have been efforts since then to
come up with a protocol and according to
Sherry,
the experience in Katrina was basically
a wake up call for doctors and hospitals
and state governments
to think about triage.
Like how should we
ration medical resources?
Like if something bad happens again,
which patients do we prioritize first?
Which patients don't we prioritize,
how do we do this?
And one of the interesting things was
that the state of Maryland decided we're
going to throw this open to our population
and have what they call deliberative
democracy.
So pull people together in a room from
all walks of life and have them grapple
with this. And I was there. Oh
you went to the very first one.
I did. I'm imagining like a town hall
meeting. Was it like that or no? Yeah,
to get started.
So just imagine a church basement in
inner city Baltimore or a conference room
meeting while the Howard
County. Thank you for coming,
for giving up this gorgeous Saturday
to have what we think is a really,
really important conversation.
There's refreshments at about 1215 we'll
take a break for you all to get lunch,
bring it back to your table. People have
been recruited to be a part of this.
And when I say people,
it's just regular folks.
So the researchers, let's call them that,
they get people together and we're
gonna get started. Good morning.
The, the sort of scenario is laid
out. So my name is Lee Doherty.
I am an intensive care doctor just
down the road at Johns Hopkins.
And what we're going to be about today
is how we make decisions about who gets
life saving resources in the,
in a situation when we literally
cannot take care of everyone. Today.
The scenario we'll talk
about is pandemic influenza.
They basically tell people, okay,
imagine a flu is sweeping the country.
Millions of people are sick,
coughing, some are dying.
The only way that folks are going to
get better or they say is if they have a
ventilator to help them
breathe. But the problem is
there just aren't enough.
This is horrible stuff.
This is a terrible situation
we're talking about
here. You have too many
patients, too few resources.
How do we choose who gets those phenols?
What are the acceptable options?
What might be the right answers?
What the researchers then essentially
lay out three different kinds of options.
Number one,
try to save the most lives or years of
life by picking people with the best
chance of [inaudible]
driving the pandemic,
such as giving the ventilators to young
people or healthier people. Number two,
picking people who will be the
most helpful during the pandemic.
So first responders, healthcare
providers, vaccine workers, et cetera.
Or number three, leave it up to
fate. Something like first come,
first serve or a lottery.
[inaudible]
seeing people nod. Does that make
sense? Okay, and then they say,
we're here to answer your questions.
Talk amongst yourselves. Right? Go ahead.
[inaudible] ever seen any situation
in life where some things are black
[inaudible] well, my immediate reaction
to the lottery was it's a leveler.
It's all the same
scientifically responsible way to go.
I think ultimately it's fair if somebody
is going to live but be very sick.
Is that, should that go into the decision?
If we've set up guidelines then yes,
it's every kind of doctor, you know
what I mean? Going to be essential.
So don't say that.
Now the good news is you're a ventilator
and four year old order and I just
think that would be the saddest thing.
Who are willing to engage in this
question, and this was right at the time,
you guys remember all the
death panel discussions.
Sarah Pailin in black and white, of
course her death pounds in there.
This started at that time
and there weren't any fist fights.
No, but as you can also hear,
I'm all for the first come first serve
and nobody has to put that in their
context at first because you there and
I got there half a second and that is,
there wasn't a lot of agreement.
I respect your opinion but I'm
just dealing with you downs.
I think that a time of crisis,
there's no room for emotions
if you're trying to say,
oh we to judge it by person, the
person. There's exceptions to the rule.
That's emotion talking
and there was no gain.
So if you're looking at everything that's
going on and that's why I have those
set up providing all of this, some
people are going to have to go.
The big findings was that
there are certain ways in
which we will not make these
decisions. There were things that the
researchers wanted to be off the table,
like not even come into the discussion.
We're not going to make decisions based
on gender, race, socioeconomic status,
people's jobs and incomes and
citizenship status and you know,
whether they had a criminal history or
where they upstanding members of society.
Those things are out of bounds. I
just want to say up front, that's not,
that's not up progress, but
those things kept popping up.
You have to have it like a young pastor
and you might have reprehensible,
alcoholic,
criminal type person and he
might have more years to live.
All the years of the pastor are going
to be more beneficial to society and the
years of this a criminal,
reprehensible, Alcoholic Dad,
Whoa, you are straying
into iffy territory there.
That is a personal,
there were people who thought that
undocumented immigrants shouldn't get
ventilators, alcoholics, smokers,
curse and the worlds will be a better
place in the most brutal terms possible.
They're saying, do you deserve
to survive? Not Can I save you,
but should I try and save you?
What's interesting is that, um,
people were really comfortable making
utilitarian choices, like saying, yeah,
that person should get the ventilator
because they're going to benefit the
greater good in some way.
But if that ever got formulated
in a slightly different way,
which is to say that person should get
the ventilator because they deserve it
more than another because their life
has more value than another person will,
then people like we're not cool with that.
And yet you would hear people say
it that way again and again and then
immediately be repulsed when they
heard someone else say it that way.
I don't think you can determine who has
done what in their life and how that's
valuable. I might think my
hairdressers want to board
their appointment, right? I want to
look good during my panic situations,
and this was particularly acute when
participants were asked the second,
can we move to an even
more controversial topic?
Really hard question, would
it be acceptable to you?
Do you think it's acceptable to ever
remove a ventilator from one patient to
give it to somebody else?
Just this one. I definitely don't
have a clear answer by style.
Some people said, well,
of course if it doesn't seem like someone
who's going to make it through the
treatments, then it we need to cut it,
cut their treatment short and passed
out. Then later on to someone else but
murder my father. There
were other people who said,
no,
you take my father off center tunnel
later and I'm still going to be shoot the
rest of your life. It's like
never going to sign off.
It's a terrible thing to think
about, but it's necessary.
So complicated.
Did they come to a conclusion? Did you,
Chad, did you hear a conclusion like,
I listen to this, I, here's what I heard.
I heard thoughtful people struggling with
a problem that is so hard to struggle
with that what they end up doing is going,
I don't know how I don't want to do this.
I'm paying more attention to your
guidelines cause I can't deal with this.
What I loved about it,
the number one response was to try to
get out of the situation and find ways to
avoid having to ration. That's the
most important part of this. Let's not,
just before we prejudge this,
what is it the researchers are going
to take away from all of this? Well,
a couple of things that they
got out of it. A number one,
remember we talked about the different
ways of deciding that they put out for
people to discuss? Well,
it turns out they wanted to combine
some of those different perspectives and
then Sherry, a lot of people thought,
sure, let's start out. Utilitarian.
Let's try and save the most lives by
picking the people who are most likely to
survive if they're likely
to survive and they need it.
But chances are there's gonna be a lot
of people who fit in that category.
So if everybody's just about
the same and we can't really,
we don't have like great science that
allows us to know which patient is going
to survive and which ones not
going to. So for that second tier,
let's do it randomly,
let's just be really,
really fair and give
everyone an equal chance.
So it's like you introduce a little bit
of fate to keep things honest. Exactly.
And the, and the research said, do
you know what? This is a good idea.
Let's see if we could maybe put
this concept into the protocol.
Am I right in thinking that these
guidelines, whatever they end up being,
are designed to avoid that sort of like
sorting based on who deserves it and who
doesn't. Yeah.
I mean there's some fairness in having
guidelines and especially guidelines that
were developed with the input
of lots of people. Yeah.
So even if we don't like
the choices that are made,
we don't end up getting the ventilator
or our loved one doesn't. Overall,
if you know that there's a protocol
out there and this is the rule,
here's why we had to adopt this rule.
It's being applied to everybody and
you're not going to be advantaged or
disadvantaged over money
or over these other things.
It sort of helps you accept it.
In theory that sounds plausible,
but when you put theory to practice,
which we're going to do
right after the break,
things get very hard. That's coming up.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
this is Jerome calling from
silver spring, Maryland.
Radiolab is supported in part by the
Alfred p Sloan Foundation enhancing public
understanding of science and
technology in the modern world.
More information
aboutSloan@wwwdotsloan.org
my life before it,
but I was just paying like sickle
cell was my life before forever.
The rapid prodigy inspired pop and hip
hop legends, but what inspired him?
I liked the angle in hip hop. It
helped me get my aggression out.
I'm Christopher Johnson
and I'm Mary Harris.
The realness is a new podcast from
wny NYC studios that takes you inside
prodigies,
legendary music and asks why the
iconic wrapper couldn't escape a single
recessive gene.
Listen and subscribe to the realness
wherever you get your podcasts.
Hey, I'm Jad Abumrad, I'm Robert Krulwich,
Radiolab and returning now to our
collaboration with the New York Times and
reporters, Sherry Fink. Uh, this is
our final stop. Many ways are hard,
hardest stop because it's the closest
we're going to come to sort of the heart
of the issues we've been talking about.
And you realize that when you get
up close as Sherry's about to, uh,
sometimes what's a success and what's
a failure or kind of hard to measure
test. We can,
we can even do the tip
VIPs and we want to value.
I remember being in Haiti after
the Haiti earthquake back in 2010.
I'm sorry, I got a 40 year old male. I
don't know what's going to happen here.
Embedded with a group of
us disaster responders,
the international medical and
surgical response team insert.
What's your name again? Sherry,
you were in this tent
hospital and at this point,
maybe about a week and a half after
the earthquake, there were so,
so many casualties, more than a
hundred thousand people could be dead.
It was patient after patient
kind of lined up in a row.
Most of the things we had are
dehydration, sepsis, festering wounds,
open fractures. Yeah,
they didn't have enough resources and
they were running out of oxygen tanks and
then they were also trying to
use these oxygen concentrators,
which pull oxygen from the environment,
but they rely on power and they were
running out of diesel for the generators.
Logistics.
We're at a critical level with our
diesel supply and oxygen for the are so
freaking today. I mean I am
freaking Frey for us and logistics.
The trade of major for this was a
hospital that had set up to do surgery.
They needed oxygen,
they didn't have enough.
So the question became who were they
going to give it to and who were they not?
And at one point, senior
sharpness lead you in ICU.
I was following a couple of the
doctors. We walked into this tent
[inaudible] and we met this woman, hi.
She had braided hair,
a white nightgown on and this
tube running into her notes.
Okay.
[inaudible] and how old are you guys?
38 30 years ago. Oh, okay. Tell
her we're almost the same age,
which gave him that Guy Betty,
how are you feeling today?
[inaudible] yeah, she's very bad.
[inaudible] did you run out of medicine?
And she was doing all right.
That's good. [inaudible]
in speaking to her, I found out that
she was from Puerto Prince, the capitol,
and that during the earthquake her house
had collapsed and everyone inside it,
she said, which was most of her
extended family. They, they died
[inaudible] you will all stay together
like you know Macy's nephew cause there's
an everyday so sorry. [inaudible]
she told me that amazingly
she had survived because
she wasn't at home when the
earthquake hit. Yes, it does.
Ending that she checked into this hospital
[inaudible] hospital downtown very
shortly before the earthquake happened
because she had had chronic lung
problems.
So she was there to get treatment and
after the earthquake she was transferred
to this American hospital.
Cool. How do you feel about the
treatment that you got here? Oh,
did the big new, was it the
good, oh, they treat me well way,
way better than anywhere that she's been
[inaudible] them, send them
Golfer. Everyone's a fanfare.
She'd been gone for the American people
could do the one that's in charge right
now because God is really using them
and put them in charge of all the thing
that is going on and I love
about love about marriage.
God bless Obama. I'm happy
to see a smile on your face.
[inaudible] I see.
I started to speak with the staff about
alright, you've been taking
care of her. Yeah. Basically
I found out that Natalie had just won
the hearts of the surgical staff there.
People loved her. She was so thankful.
But she has a chronic illness,
which is severe heart failure
and hypertension and it's
very hard for us to see
her leave. [inaudible]
told me they had plans
to take her off oxygen.
They were going to turn down the
oxygen slowly to try to make it more
comfortable and then they were going to
send her off to a Haitian facility that
didn't have oxygen, but where
she would presumably die.
And if you're thinking in terms
of hard triage theory, you know,
this makes sense because they
were trying to save oxygen.
She has a chronic problem that
probably won't get better.
So that's like the theory of it. But
the practice of it was quite different.
She had absolutely no idea that
they were about to do this.
She had all this hope for her future
should get well.
She prayed to God that she would
have an opportunity to earn a living,
but I'm [inaudible] seven wants to
go there to the dog. She wants to go.
When she did the Astrodome,
is there any way possible then the people
would give her like somewhere to stay
that some kind of shelter? One that I am,
I mean I'm a journalist and I don't
know the answer to that, but I,
I don't know what to say. It's
such a hard situation right now.
How did your mind start with that?
Where the nurse who was doing the triage,
who'd made that decision
to cut off her oxygen?
I'm Patrick Cadillac. I'm the commander
for the insert team. Had never met her.
No, I never met the patient,
but that's the role pattern that
we're running out of oxygen.
The country itself doesn't have
oxygen, so I have to make the decision.
No, she can't cut the oxygen, turn it off.
I have to look at the greater good
that we can provide with the limited
resources. We have Jack Right now.
Oh, I see. Okay. And so
then I followed that woman.
I wanted to see this on a human level
as well as on the abstract level.
The transporters came a few
hours later, look around,
go ahead and get him up there. He
was the 82nd airborne actually,
who were providing that service. They
were amazing and they came to pick her up.
She traveled, they saw she was
on oxygen. They said, okay,
we're going to put her on
their portable oxygen tanks,
and the representative from
the hospital said, oh no, no.
She doesn't get oxygen
ready to go,
so they yanked the
oxygen Durbar all right,
ready to strapped her onto
a stretcher. [inaudible]
lifted her up,
stuck her in the back of this Humvee
ambulance Fletcher head by going with,
okay, we're going to hop
in your car. Go home.
I rode with her coming
up. Okay, mom, I'm fine.
Well,
she started getting short of breath.
Oh, so you hadn't
[inaudible]
put this asthma inhaler in her mouth.
She kept hitting it over and over again.
She thought it was oxygen. It was
horrific to watch her start. Sorry
to suffer. I felt complicit.
I was doing a story and I knew very well
that they had chosen for her to to die
and just watching didn't feel
it didn't feel right and so,
hello. You guys see, Whoa, whoa.
Watch that movie.
It stopped at this hospital and I nodded
over toward her and some of the medical
staff went to to look at
her, how they go in glaze.
No one could see she was in
distress. They brought her inside.
She was really struggling to breathe,
but then she's definitely big time CHF.
I saw one of my medical school professors,
an emergency doctor and
I told them about her.
Is it, whose is this? Sorry,
is that hers? Yes. Here honey,
this mama going, you sit up. Okay Mama.
Okay.
It's like no, it's like back a
little bit and she improvised
[inaudible] write it out.
She used like all these diuretics
to get fluid off her lungs,
nitrates or anything.
And he found one tank of oxygen
that had a teeny bit last minute
breathe, breathe better. Okay.
And
he was able to extend her life.
All right, well I'll see you tomorrow.
[inaudible]
ultimately I actually felt
a responsibility for her
that outlasted the story
that I did. Um, and so
after that came out, I,
I did attempt to help her. Really? Yeah.
Well, I, uh,
found a charitable group that was
willing to bring her to the u s under a
certain type of visa program that
allowed for humanitarian, uh,
like a medical treatment. And the,
the cardiologists who had examined
her and Haiti had thought she had, uh,
a rheumatic heart disease that was causing
her lung problems and that it could
be surgically corrected. But
when she came to the u s in fact,
it was found that she had a much more
serious condition and she really needed a
transplant and she didn't, didn't make it.
Does this make you wonder?
So here you've got a rule and maybe
in some broad way it's helping,
but in that vehicle, looking at this,
you wanted to break the rules for very
moral and decent reasons in these extreme
circumstances where life and death
are wrestling with each other.
Can you make rules? I mean, I, yeah,
because it's like you can't fault the
people for taking her off the oxygen and
you can't fault you for trying
to get her on the oxygen. So, uh,
what's the conclusion to draw?
Well, let's not give up. You know,
the conclusion is let's not give
up. Like it turns out there was,
there were options for this woman.
It turns out that somebody
was able to extend her life.
Now you could very well argue that she
should have died in that moment because
look at all the resources that
were spent. But I just feel like,
like there was some value in her
existence. There was so much value.
She came to the u s and my God,
she took up a collection for all the
patients back in the Haitian hospital who
she was friends with. She contributed
til the day she died and she,
she changed my life too. So I don't
know how to do the math on this one. Uh,
this is the problem.
No, well [inaudible] real
quickly guidelines is required,
like a lack of compassion,
the cold hard rigidness of
it and everything you're
talking about has to do with
compassion. This is
Simon Adler by the way,
our producer and how do you make
compassion work on that large of a scale
without caring about people and then you
care about some people more than other
people and then, oh shit,
now, now we're hurting.
That's a very good point. If
you don't systematize it, you,
you risk choosing people based on
factors that are really not fair.
Exactly.
Because part of me does wonder like what
if Natalie weren't such a nice person?
Would her, would that have
changed things? Well, you know,
if Natalie was a mean person that I don't
think I would have felt any better or
watching her suffer. It's just
about the person in front of you.
And I think that the
more unbearable it is,
so the more you have to
look someone in the eyes,
the more it makes us try to figure
out creative ways to avoid doing it.
Okay. But I do feel you,
I'm somehow refusing to acknowledge
the subject point. It really,
really gets tough. You say, let's,
let's avoid that toughness
over and over again.
Let's know I'm facing the real problem,
which is that it's a
problem to have to ration,
but we're not gonna figure out the best
way to ration because there is no one
best way because everyone in society
will have a different view on that.
I think that that's in some
way unimpeachable I think
you're absolutely right.
We should always strive to
not have to make the choice,
but with we do have to make the
choice. How do we do it? Well,
that's a very tough question.
Let me tell you that I think what you've
hit upon here is an impossible piece of
human business, rationing,
triage, whatever you call it,
is an inhuman act, which
humans are trying to do,
but the of their humanity
makes it impossible. So what we've
got here is we've kind of, you know,
a real deep problem the other
than God role and nobody fits it.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
we have so many people to
thank for this. Uh, our, uh,
let's start with Lily Sullivan and Pat
Walters for really getting us thinking
about all of this. Thank you
lily. Thank you pat. Thank you.
Also to prs the world,
a version of the Haiti story first
appeared on that show and a huge thanks to
New York Times correspondent, Sherry Fink.
All the stories you heard in this hour
came as a result of her reporting for the
book. Five days at memorial.
Sherry has an article that coincides
with this podcast about the Maryland
project. Uh,
we will link you to it from
radiolab.org or you can read it at n y
times.com/triage and thank you New York
Times for lending us Sherry for a bit of
time. Yes. This story was produced
by Simon [inaudible]. I'm in
band for Life Adler, Annie,
or can be only one McKeown.
We had original music
from both Simon and Annie,
also from Taylor decree and Kenneth
Kershner. I'm Chad. I'm Rod.
I'm Robert Krulwich. Thanks for listening.